The first problem we'll consider,
is the problem of sequence alignment or
at a distance.
This often comes up in the study of
genetics, or as part of spell checkers.
For example suppose that we
are given two genetic sequences and
we want to line them up
as best as possible,
minimizing the needed insertions,
deletions, and
changes to the characters, that would
be needed to convert one to the other.
And we'll do this according
to some cost function
that represents how likely these
changes are to have occurred in nature.
Another way to think about this,
is to say that I have aligned these
elements of the sequence here.
And left some of the elements unmatched.
In general we say that we're given two
sequences, X and Y, over some alphabet.
And we want to find an alignment between
them, that is, a subset of the pairs
of elements of the sequence, so
that each letter appears only once
in this alignment and the pairs don't
cross, like in this example here.
The cost of an alignment
comes from two sources.
What is the number of
unmatched characters,
which we can write mathematically as n +
m minus twice the size of the alignment.
This corresponds to the number
of insertions or deletions, or
matching with these dashed
characters in this figure.
The other part of the cost comes form
the matching of the two characters.
We will notate that cost
with this function alpha.
Typically alpha is zero,
when the two characters are the same.
And the problem here of course,
is to find the alignment
that minimizes this cost.